hi guys thank you so much for coming in
I know Khan is exhausting it is Saturday
evening and we all are a little loopy at
this point I appreciate you coming in
we're moving into season four and we
have so many fun things to talk about
but just talking about it first I know
that the season 4 premiere is going to
be a tribute to the one and only Luke
Perry how will we see Luke's legacy and
Fred Andrews legacy be addressed in this
episode I think a lot of it through
Archie storyline I think that's part of
his storyline in season 4 is honoring
his father's legacy and you know I think
they'll be bits and pieces throughout
the whole season where you can defend
and out of that you guys left us on a
major cliffhanger there was Spring Break
flash-forwards people covered in blood
only seeing jugheads beanie Kol when you
read that initial scene what was your
reaction finally get to take the hat off
for three people who were covered in
blood
what was it like for you guys to film
that scene cold cold very cold and early
in the morning naked yeah yes actually I
think it was kind of like I would think
I was saying to myself like there's no
way yeah there was gonna be some very
clever way that they spin this around we
didn't know what it was and I'm sure
they didn't know what it was either but
it's weird we'll figure it out yeah I
was just like what does this mean for
season four yeah obviously all of our
cliffhanger is usually allude to like
whatever the mystery is gonna be next
season
I guess it's his jughead dead we had
quite the big Cheryl bombshell at the
end of season 3 as we welcomed Jason
blossom into thistle house come back
home he's still dead really just a
little bit a little bit
Madalena can you talk us through
Cheryl's mindset right now and kind of
what's going through her head
well Cheryl hasn't had a lot of losses
in her life and I imagine that what's
going on is that she just really misses
Jason and the core for being and so like
when she and at the photo at the farm
she was being kind of hypnotized but
also speaking to his body while being
under hypnosis and that really mess with
her mental state and so now she like
feels like she had her brother back and
so she's kind of done this thing and
she's got back to that state of mental
imbalance to like kind of fill the Jason
sized hole in her heart with a
taxidermied body maybe in real life but
you don't know about that yeah so not
only do we have brother Jason back we
also have the introduction of real
brother Charles and I'm curious to know
how is this gonna shake things up for
Betty and Jughead moving forward in
season 4 now that they have a shared
half-brother I I don't think it's gonna
change much for them it's very erotic
Lee charged regardless the introduction
of this third sibling party is not
really going to change too much of that
they're still incredible tension it's
telling you guys having kids oh yeah but
not related by blood we're like we're
not related yes of course not so that
should be fine yeah I mean it's really
early in the sea we haven't an unveils
anything Riverdale yeah he could be
another imposter for all we know
my dad Oh God maybe that maybe that
would be related
I'm really excited to see what's next
for Veronica because parents are away
I'm assuming these gonna play oh yeah
we have the house to ourselves and we
definitely take advantage of that she's
gonna be throwing some wild parties this
year ah that's much parties legal
guardian but I don't know we're healers
KJ what are you excited for Archie to go
through in his senior year
football lots of football this season
that's gonna be good lots of Chelsea
Melton this season - so something
bridgie Archie action I feel like when
we talk about Archie in football you
can't also not mention music it's not
also gonna be a storyline yeah actually
yeah musics gonna be another one for
sure I think we all sat our own band the
garage band called the Archie's the core
for amazing he's on drums I'm singing
and planning to talk she plays the
tambourine the timex
name what is the phone yet what script
yeah talking about huh you literally
aplenty the saxophone yeah it says
you're playing sax yeah it does
he's joke no it actually your accent is
to pull your little bit is our senior
year though we're gonna get more
football does that mean we're getting
more Vixens battling yeah
exclude that he still no okay how do you
know that what you should do probably is
only when Roberto wants her to be she's
balancing a lot she is she's working
she's girls at the for the FBI to help
so she's not hopefully won't have time
for the victims because I really hate
cheerleading such a fun thing we know
Tony's also a vixen they can do it I
think we need to switch into a little
bit of a Riverdale romance rundown no
romance rundown showers let's kick it
off with Shoni nataline what can you
tease that's coming up for Cheryl and
Tony well Cheryl is keeping a dead body
in her basement and her girlfriend
doesn't know about it so let's say rocky
roads are ahead but as far as we know
right now they aren't very happy so
we'll see what happens
Cheryl need some happiness she W in
happiness but it wouldn't be sure I
blossom if it's not a little chaos
mister this is true
uh what about barchi what's coming up
for Branca and Archie in season four all
right she's looking pretty solid at my
right TJ you're a solid good because
they had a lot of ups and downs last
year we'll be seen any lingering
interactions between romka and Reggie
there there'll definitely be like a
confrontation about them just I think
Reggie has some hurt feelings he's got a
bromance now so he does and what about
Betty and Jughead I think they're going
strong
jagad goes to Pratt School this season
so he's only back in Riverdale on the
weekends so that distance oh yeah and I
think that's going to inevitably put
stress on the relationship between Betty
and Jughead I think it might be a little
bit tense they might fall
turn away from each other only to come
back together way stronger and yes I
think they're gonna I think they're
gonna be really good
well said Cole thanks really nice really
nice stuff um it's still early in the
season I feel like now is the
time for you guys to shout out your
Riverdale wish list what is something
that you would levy from your character
the season we'll put it out into the
universe and hopefully by the end of the
season we'll get to see it
babbling what would you like to see from
Cheryl smile yeah I don't know I'm not
for whatever yeah I'm cool maybe some
more a tree
yes house party or two your skills are
amazing by the way is that fun for you
it's very fun I enjoyed a lot when they
let me shoot yeah it's a legal thing but
sometimes cool what do you wanna see for
Jughead I'd like to see him do a bit
more riding and I think that's kind of
the route we're gonna be taking it
sounds a lot like he's gonna be more of
a season 1 joking you're gonna screw
larger by the because I'm gaining power
I'm like a Super Saiyan no I think I
think just a little bit more riding
would be nice and a return to sort of
emo sad boy I want to see Veronica I
think because we kind of catch her
applying for college so I kind of want
to see how that process pans out and
seeing if she goes into like a really
good school and then probably seeing her
not get in because then the show would
have to move to wherever Veronica would
just leave everyone's gonna be like no
Community College I wonder how they're
gonna swing that Veronica declines
Harvard SEPA Archie's some clothes on
maybe maybe he can get some plastic
surgery to get rid of his because I've
just been 3 hours of makeup 3 shirtless
same for these sweats the eggs on he's a
trouper though yeah Lilly buddy she's
been put through the wringer quite a few
times all the time
I mean and that's never gonna change but
I think I would like to see her be a
little duo with Veronica again they're
so cute when they're together now we're
scenes together they were always ask me
when they're together
are you very cute together very cute
very and then just real quick another
thing that was really cute was getting
to watch the hustlers trailer Lily you
looked amazing in it what does it mean
for you to be part of this movie and
getting to work with Jennifer Lopez I
mean it was really freaking cool to be a
part of all these badass women and just
to work among them it was just a cool
experience so different from Riverdale
you know you kind of feel like a little
it's it's weird to go from a set that
you're on for nine months straight to a
movie where you're getting to know
everyone again so it kind of makes you
appreciate the fact that we're such a
family and I can you know I've got my
family and friends with me for most of
the year but you know it was it was fun
to meet new people and it was a good
experience yeah
all right guys lastly shout out to the
fans one word to describe the beginning
of season four yeah that's perfect
that's perfect thank you guys so much
be sure to keep it locked to eat you
guys were comic-con content I'll talk to
you later bye you guys you guys
you